The full It: Chapter Two trailer debuted July
18th, 2019 at San Diego Comic-Con, promising
a thrilling conclusion to director Andy Muschietti's
adaptation of Stephen King's terrifying novel.
The trailer suggests a devout and appropriate
faithfulness to the flick's source material.
Let's have a look at the chilling details.
The trailer opens with narration from Mike,
who unlike the rest of the now-adult Losers
stayed in Derry, Maine.
"The farther away, the hazier it all gets.
But me, I never left.
I remember all of it."
Then there's a shot of the sewers, where a
torrent of water rolls through a tunnel, ensaring
a young victim.
This scene doesn't seem to be from the It
novel; it instead looks like a nod to another
film adaptation of a King classic: The 1980
Stanley Kubrick film The Shining.
The famous trailer for that film uses a static
shot from the movie of some unassuming elevator
doors, but as the film's title and credits
pop up onscreen, massive volume of blood gushes
out even as the doors stay closed.
It's unlikely in the extreme that Muschietti
would have included such a similar shot by
coincidence.
In King's novel, the number seven is a sort
of mystical totem that helps to empower the
Losers to take on a malevolent being from
beyond time and space.
When Mike calls the adult Losers back to Derry,
however, their chances against Pennywise are
immediately dealt a blow by the fact that
their number is reduced to six.
Stan Uris, the most logical of the bunch,
remembers just a bit too much about that long-ago
summer upon receiving Mike's invitation.
Just minutes after receiving Mike's call,
Stan commits suicide.
It: Chapter Two will clearly carry over this
plot point from the book; in every single
one of the trailer's shots that feature the
entire adult Losers' Club, Stan isn't there.
In one of the new trailer's most harrowing
sequences, James McAvoy's Bill is seen pursuing
a young boy through a carnival funhouse.
He loses the youngster in the hall of mirrors,
finally managing to catch up to him, but they're
separated by thick glass.
In a horrible echo of his brother Georgie's
fate in the opening of the first film, Pennywise
materializes to menace the child as a helpless
Billy frantically kicks at the glass.
Funhouses are meant to be a little scary,
sure, but those gently swaying pendulums would
make any child in their right mind run screaming
from the attraction.
They bear more than a passing resemblance
to Pennywise himself, and while some of them
are smiling, others sport a look of wide-eyed,
abject terror.
It's a visual signifier that, as Bill enters
the funhouse, he's entering the monster's
domain.
In a blink-and-you'll-miss-it moment, an unidentified
man is dragged through the halls of what appears
to be a mental institution.
Oblivious to the staff member trying to place
him into a chokehold, he's fixated with rapturous
joy on a red balloon Pennywise's calling card
floating outside.
As fans of the novel are well aware, this
is no random patient.
This is the adult Henry Bowers, who as a child
terrorized the Losers' Club and fell under
the sway of Pennywise, causing him to kill
his abusive father.
"That's right!
And you will, too, Henry!
Make it a wonderful day!
Kill him!"
In King's novel, Henry is committed to Juniper
Hill asylum for his crime, where he spends
27 years obsessing over his encounter with
forces beyond his comprehension.
When Pennywise returns, Bowers escapes, with
an assist from the shapeshifting entity, and
tries to kill the Losers.
When the Losers reconvene in the book, they
decide to split up to individually explore
old haunts.
Of course, Pennywise takes this opportunity
to taunt them all, assaulting them with reality-warping
experiences that turn the most innocent of
their formative memories on their heads.
One of the most memorable of these sequences
involves Richie Tozier, who pays a visit to
the town's park with its hilariously tacky
statue of Paul Bunyan.
Richie's solo adventure is briefly depicted
in the trailer, as he sees Pennywise gliding
along with a bundle of balloons above that
very statue.
In the book, Henry Bowers' gang once chased
him to that exact spot, where the Bunyan statue
came to life, chasing him down with its tremendous
ax.
The statue morphs into a bizarre version of
Pennywise and proceeds to warn him of his
impending doom.
"All right, Rich.
What are you afraid of?"
"Clowns."
In one shot near the trailer's end, Mike is
in a crude tent, as the world appears to be
shaking itself to pieces around him.
He doesn't appear frightened, though.
He seems almost joyous.
This may actually be exactly what's happening
in this shot, as it appears to be a depiction
of a ritual the Losers engaged in as children
in the novel.
This could be a weird kind of flashback, or
the filmmakers may have chosen to move it
to the present day.
It involves a "Smoke-Hole," a construct built
for a Native American ritual which Ben discovers
and which is meant to bring enlightenment.
Sitting in an enclosure while burning a dry,
smoky fire, the Losers all experience visions,
one of which reveals that Pennywise came to
Earth from another dimension millennia ago.
It's impact, similar to that of a small asteroid,
created the deep caverns under Derry where
Pennywise makes its home.
The Losers are finally able to kill It for
good by engaging in the Ritual of Chüd, the
details of which were revealed to Bill by
Maturin, a turtle-shaped eternal force of
light diametrically opposed to It.
The Losers must use their wit, knowledge,
and love for each other to essentially will
It into submission.
In the novel, it's a battle that takes place
purely in the psychic realm, where belief
and purity of intention are capable of defeating
even the most malevolent forces.
In the trailer, the surviving Losers certainly
seem to be about to engage in some sort of
ritual.
Screenwriter Gary Dauberman has said that
a form of the Ritual of Chüd will be featured
in It: Chapter Two, describing his writing
of the sequence as:
"...trying to find the most focused, accessible
way into some of more metaphysical aspects
of that book."
It'll be interesting to see how he and Muschietti
tackled one of the most abstract climaxes
in all of horror literature, but they have
our confidence, and King's as well.
In a tweet, the author said simply,
"Looking forward to It: Chapter Two?
You should be.
I've seen it, and it's terrific."
We'll know if we agree when the flick hits
screens September 6th.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about It: Chapter
Two are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.